one-off hearing today on food and fuel
price inflation we're very grateful that
four of the supermarkets have come to
give evidence to us this morning and so
we have a Gordon gaffer who's the
commercial director at Tesco good
morning Chris cornerfield who's the
chief commercial officer at Asda good
morning Rhian Bartlett who is the food
commercial director at Sainsbury's hi
and David Potts who's the CEO of
Morrison so good morning to all four of
you
um we're going to want to ask questions
today on two issues first is the
long-term structural issues that might
exist to evidence higher prices for food
and fuel and to help us understand what
those might be and how they might be
changing and second is to understand the
short-term measures that your companies
are taking to help your customers in
this particularly difficult time with
the cost of living crisis and before we
get into questions I should just say
that we're delighted to welcome Robert
Goodwill who's the chair of the deafra
select committee and Ian Byrne who's a
member of the deaf select committee who
are joining us today
um so to begin with um presumably all of
your companies recognize that we're
still in the midst of a cost of living
crisis we're a very significant number
of your customers are unable to afford
to buy the food and fuel that they need
to support their households I'm assuming
everybody agrees with those
um and it was announced today that
inflation has come down a little bit to
around eight percent
um but for the public I think that
translates as meaning that prices are
still going up at a rate of 80 is that
also right yeah so customers are
struggling and prices are still going up
so the question that many have been
asking including the Prime Minister the
chancellor the competition of markets
Authority and others is whether and I'm
quoting the government here whether the
supermarkets have been behaving or not
in their pricing
um and one of the accusations is that
um all of your companies I think for the
exception of with the exception of
Morrisons have been making increased
profits and therefore have you been
doing enough to keep down the prices of
the food that you supply to your
customers so I just want to take that
question head on and in the context of
increased profits are you doing enough
to help so at Gordon um gaffer for Tesco
are you doing enough to help your
customers uh thank you Mr chairman
um I would start by saying that um at
Tesco at the moment
we are the most competitive we have ever
been we have a real powerful combination
in our opinion of Aldi price match for
example which we have recently expanded
and just to go into a little bit of
detail what that means we have 700 lines
that we price match every week to Aldi
and customers when they come to Tesco
shops are guaranteed that they will not
pay anything more for those lines in
Tesco
but there's just not it's not the only
thing we're doing so for example we have
a low everyday prices campaign where we
lock prices and that's over a thousand
lines in the majority of our stores
fixed for periods of
um three months for example and they
cover all the markets with regards to
how we price match
and finally through clubcard prices you
will have in any given week about 8 000
prices where we go up to 50 promotions
and offer our club card holders real
unbeatable value
I wanted to tackle the profitability
question had on we have not made more
profit year-on-year we have actually
made seven percent less profit versus
our last Financial year
um so I think it's important to be clear
at the answer from that point Mr
chairman and maybe you can help me
because you all run very complicated
businesses so I I had a quick look at
the annual accounts for each of your
companies and specifically compared your
performance before the covid lockdowns
to the last Financial year because of
course covert made things much more
difficult to understand and to take
Tesco as an example according to your
2018-19 annual accounts you made a
profit of 1.6 billion pounds and in your
2122 accounts made a profit of 2.03
billion pounds so just as a very basic
review of the accounts you've increased
your profit quite significantly there
haven't you
when I look at our group
um profits we are we are a business made
out of various companies including
retail wholesale uh international
business Etc in the Czech Republic
slovaki Hungary and Ireland
um our profitability has hovered between
three to four percent in the last four
or five years and I quote from our group
accounts since since 2019.
um and as I say the prophet Sierra for
the group for the global business are
are down
um and I would like to remind maybe the
committee just in the interest of
transparency
we have sold more and on here we have
made less and that is within uh which is
Public public information we have had a
really big savings program at Tesco we
have saved 550 million pounds we have
given our colleagues
um 15 pay increase in the last year 22
percent over the last couple of years
and if you do the maths I guess between
what we sold and what we made it's a
significant investment in our customer
offer as well as our colleagues which
we're really quite proud of actually I'm
sorry it's cutting but the public Will
Will just look at the numbers I've
presented to you in your your group
profits have gone up from before the
covert pandemic to now from 1.6 billion
to 2.03 billion that's a bigger number
I'm sure there are lots of reasons
underneath it but essentially you've got
more cash in the bank at the end of the
day uh based on your reported accounts
so the question is why given the covet
pandemic the energy crisis this the
increase in cost for your supply The
increased cost to your customers how can
it be possible that you're making
hundreds of millions of pounds in
additional profit
able Mr chairman around I'm looking at
the numbers are adjusted the operating
profit for the group
in 2019 were 2.6 and in 2023 there are
2.6 again so there may be I don't know
maybe some discrepancies in what we're
comparing but it is I need to move on
but just so you know for the record this
is the Tesco PLC annual report and
financial statements from 2018 to 2019
where a chap called Alan Stewart who is
your Chief Financial Officer reported a
group statutory profit before tax of at
1.6 billion pounds and then when I
turned to the same report from 2022 as a
different chap this time but he reports
on the same measure 2.03 billion pounds
so I'm just reading them I'm referring
to our latest issued accounts for 2020
223 so that may be the discrepancy I'm
happy to I guess
thank you Mr Comfort from uh the
perspective Asda are you doing enough to
help your customers right now
so in a similar way to what we've just
discussed so if you looked at the Asda
full year 2022 to account sales were
flat on a year on year basis but profit
of the adjusted ebitda perspective was
down by 25 percent
so that reflects what we've been trying
to do to manage the inflation that we've
been seeing we all know the uh drivers
that we've seen of inflation in the in
the UK Market uh whether that's when
some of the supply chain issues through
the pandemic whether the wheat pound the
labor market costs uh the war in Ukraine
certainly uh affecting food and energy
prices out there we've done a series of
uh customer facing initiatives with a
launch of just Essentials which is our
entry price range
um in all of our stores we have a
dropped and lot campaign where we're not
only we've dropped their prices of
products we've also held them for a
period of time we've launched a Rewards
program a loyalty program so the more
that you shop at Asda the more you get
rewarded for that as well as investing
in the in some of the Key Food offers
out there and in our cafes we we offer
kids
um the chance to eat for one pound
um
as a lot of the my competitive set have
also done we've also invested in our
colleagues as well with a series of pay
increases
which has been necessary as we've faced
into this cost of living crisis
thank you and the as the accounts are
quite difficult to read because you've
had a significant change in the way that
your business is owned and financed one
of the things I've noticed is that your
cost of borrowing has gone from in 2018
2019 from 66 million pounds to the year
2122 uh to nearly half a billion pounds
why if your debt payments had to go up
so significantly and what does that mean
for your customers so as you say we've
had an ownership change during that time
period and therefore as a consequence of
the way we are our owned and are
structured is different so as you were
comparing
um three three years prior to that all I
would say is therefore that bit is then
be factored in as we've looked to our
business and our account and therefore
despite that as what you're talking to
in terms of the financial structure
we're still investing in the customer
offer that's why we have invested in
just the just Essentials as rewards
dropped in lot programs as well as cafes
for all our customers uh Rianne Bartlett
coming to you next from a Sainsbury's
perspective again the same question I've
just looked at the annual accounts 2018
19 there was profit before tax of 239
million pounds 21 22 854 million pounds
has been a significant increase in
profit at Sainsbury's are you doing
enough to help your customers
so the first thing we would like to say
is we're acutely aware of the impact of
the cost of living crisis on our
customers and also on our colleagues and
how difficult that they're all finding
it right now
we've spent 560 million pounds on
keeping prices low battling inflation
and we're doing absolutely everything we
can to keep prices as low for customers
as possible
like uh Tesco and Asda we have a range
of price
mechanics and activations that we
choose to invest in to help our
customers so we also have an Aldi price
match
offer we have about 300 products in that
they're the products our customers buy
the most frequently we've been very
choiceful about making sure that that's
covering a set of products that are in
their baskets week in week out we also
have price lock and we have loyalty
pricing
and in addition to that we have an
economy range called Stamford Street and
we've just brought all of our lowest
price products under one brand so that
they're really easy to find
terms of the accounts that you reference
actually our most recent year that we've
just published we made 690 million so
our input costs are not being fully
passed through to our Shelf prices we've
submitted lots of detail on that to the
CMA we've had very good discussions and
dialogue with the CMA but we are
inflating behind our input costs and
we're inflating wherever possible behind
the market thank you and David Potts for
Morrisons I suppose the Saving Grace is
your profit's gone down not up uh from
2018 19 compared to 2122 so I can't
quite put the same question to you that
you're running away with excess profits
but what are you doing to help your
customers with the cost of living crisis
oh thank you chair and uh thank you for
the opportunity to be here today I think
it's a privilege for Morrisons and I'm
very pleased to be here in person myself
I think
we are akulia aware of
the pressure that many millions of you
know
ordinary people have come under as a
result of this cost of living crisis and
food inflation
in particular I know that since it
started we have donated four million to
food banks to make sure
no one is Left Behind in that same
period we've helped our customers by
collecting the goods they want to donate
to food banks and delivering them there
ourselves a further 8 million then that
does come on top of the 12 million that
I know
members of the slight committee will be
aware we donated from the company during
the pandemic to food banks I think
as far as what have we done this year
well so far I reported on Thursday our
profits were down 10 half year one
as we faced into lower prices
by investing early in lower prices we
are as close now as this company has
ever been to to Aldi and Little Prices
um and my I think final remark would be
we have introduced a brand called Savers
which according to cantar last week who
comment on the industry on various
matters is the fastest growing sort of
fighter brand the budget brand in the UK
this year and I believe that's because
we've lowered prices with a tougher
policy for us to get through with those
prices of Savers we've made delivery uh
more attractive and we've increased the
item count to 240 for of that items and
we've put them where people can see them
uh
uh and buy them and so
I think it's a very fair question and
there's more we can do but I'm very
confident that so far we're getting at
every cost we can in order to put it
into prices
thank you and then just very lastly for
me
um all of you are very large employers
as well as serving very significant
numbers of consumers and I heard
recently specifically their Asda
employees but I'm sure it applies in
other supermarkets of employees having
to go to the food bank to pick up the
food donations of food they'd stacked in
their own Supermarket because they can't
make ends meet so I just want to ask
each of you very quickly whether you're
a living wage employer
um at Gordon
we are as I said we are really quite
proud to have given
um a 15 increase to our colleagues I
would I would like I just unconscious of
time so it's just a short answer are you
a living wage employer yes or no yeah a
real real living wage employers thank
you Chris Asda you are Ryan Sainsbury's
David Morrison National living wage 10
42 we're paying 10.92 with a 15 discount
okay
okay we're gonna move on to some
questions of time
um we're going to go now into fuel
prices and then food prices
um and dive in some of these issues in a
bit more details
um so Anthony Magnum please off your
price thank you Chad I'm going to start
with um you miss together because I
think Tesco's has got the most number of
fuel courts out of the panelists uh with
us today um can you just give us an idea
as to what has caused uh the increase in
fuel uh prices
um both from outside and within your
control
oh yeah thank you for the question
um
fuel prices have um seen a significant
increase driven by the impact of the uh
unfortunate war in Ukraine we shouldn't
forget that more than 90 percent of the
price that you see at the pump is
actually made of input costs
um taxes as well as duties
and the significant spike in the prices
that you saw at the pumps was largely
driven by factors outside of our control
and and in terms of what is within your
control because you have huge purchasing
power you can buy in a wholesale Manner
and yet prices have remained stubbornly
High across actually all four of your
fuel all four of your company's fuel
courts have very very high prices and
continue to do so so you know what is
what is within your purchasing power to
actually reduce those prices
um it's probably important to point out
the prices have reduced very
significantly I would say
um if we compare from January till now I
believe the current average is around 16
Pence per liter cheaper than what it was
at the time and again versus the Peaks
that we saw last year from memory again
were about 28
cheaper at the pumps for for motorists
we do
buy from eight different suppliers we
uplift from over 30 different locations
and we're quite proud of of how we buy
and how we make sure that what is within
our control which is fairly limit I
would say because you have to refer to
the plots price on on fuel L SDK input
raw material and that's significant
chunk of
um that that price is
[Music]
Duty and tax in fact 53 Pence per liter
is is still unity plus you have v80 at
20 on top I mean I I don't take much
comfort in the fact that you're saying
that the prices are down from a very
very high level in the first instance I
think consumers are wondering why they
still remain incredibly high and I think
there is also huge concern around
transparency within the sector
um I know Mr gallis will come on to this
but actually take Northern Ireland as an
example where there is greater
transparency around fuel prices and the
RAC is reporting that actually there's a
significantly lower price offered to
Consumers as a result can I ask I'll
start with you miss Gavin because I'm
sorry I'm focusing on you but I will
come into other come to others in a
second but what consideration have you
had about actually enhancing that
transparency either in real terms or
going on to a Northern Ireland model
where it's a weekly presentation of your
figures which has actually seen
significantly reduced prices offered to
Consumers and also given the fact that
that actually beats any of the com any
of the points that you made around you
know how you're purchasing and what
you're doing because they've been able
to keep it consistently low through the
pandemic and through the fuel crisis as
well
um first and foremost I started by
saying that we we do compete locally and
our pricing policy is structured to
compete uh locally and we're
um you know really Keen to make sure
that we we stick with it um yeah we are
a retailer in Northern Ireland we have
19 sites uh so we are part of Northern
Ireland and how we deliver fuel fuel to
motorists uh over there sorry can I just
jump in there so um can you can you give
me a comparison right now for what
you're charging for petrol and diesel in
Northern Ireland versus what you'll be
charging in England because presumably
you're part of that transparency system
so as I say we we do price locally and
within the Tesco policy we have a spread
of about 10 pence per liter which we try
not to deviate from let's not forget
fuel pricing is very volatile and any
one point you could have locations that
would be within that spread
um on your question specifically around
transparency I would like to remind the
community we we do
um put our fuel prices outside each of
our locations we display them on bitcoin
rings and we're very open before you
drive into a Tesco versus maybe one of
our competitors and and just to answer
specifically the question on on
transparency we would welcome more
transparency on price and farewell we
have no objection whatsoever to to
transparent prices in fact we would
welcome the system that is in Northern
Ireland where you can go online and
compare it it is not not not something
we would be against yeah I mean I just
make the point I don't think it offers
people much comfort to say or
advertising what the price is outside
when they have very little options to be
able to get yeah well precisely Nissan
sales which you have to show those
prices but if you have little
alternative it makes no difference I
think I think the consideration has to
be how do you ensure that you
collectively given the fact that you are
the biggest fuel core owners or one of
the biggest groups of fuel core owners
are actually competing at a price that
is fair and reasonable to Consumers and
fair unreasonable pricing is at the
heart of the Tesco operation
um just in terms of option Tesco has 511
petrol fuel stations out of about 8 300
in the UK so market share with regards
to sites is about six percent the actual
share with regards to volume 16 percent
uh and and we think because we have busy
sites and convenient locations that are
competitively priced motorists do reward
us with their business
I mean I'm gonna thank you very much
your sponsors I'm going to just quickly
ask you if I made sure would all of you
collectively be happy to enter into a
model that is absolutely akin to what's
being done in Northern Ireland sorry
mascalas I'm stealing a lot of your your
points but
um would you all be happy to enter into
a system that would actually provide
better live priced fuel fuel price
transparency
um this Comfort it's a yes or no would
be very helpful in terms of time and I
will come back okay in which case then
yes absolutely yes
I think anything that can benefit
consumers would be happy to look at we
certainly have some work to do then on
our side on this can I can I come to
humans Butler which is what are you
expecting to actually in terms of bring
down uh prices and create more sort of
price stability within your market and
what you're able to offer consumers yeah
so um pricing today has actually
returned to
pre
-russia Ukraine war pricing
so that's a good thing we've been
through a year
um a year and a bit of
very deep instability in Supply which
you will have seen
and that has stabilized over the last
number of weeks and months and so we now
sit at 140 1 140 around that level
which could be compared to more normal
levels
um
the way that we price petrol is also
locally that's how the market operates
and we aim to be the cheapest or the
second cheapest in all the catchments
that we operate in run out of about 300
catchments and again as you're aware the
CMA have been looking in a great deal of
detail at this Market it's been a very
productive process we've engaged closely
with them
um
they haven't found particular
competition concerns although they are
publishing Fuller report next week but
what they have found is the presence of
a supermarket in a catchment it actually
helps to keep prices low
so I think if they um recommend an open
data platform like the one you refer to
we'd be very supportive of something
like that listen I I mean you've
mentioned the CMA and I'm in danger of
wandering into the next question so I
won't do that but I can't can I just
make the point that the CMA said that
actually from a supermarket perspective
that you know you collectively have been
very bad
um are providing information and make
that point just that you can do better
on that um I've I've steered into Mr
gallas's territory so I'll hand over to
him and and just to be clear I don't
think the CMA named which of your
businesses had not been forthcoming in
engaging with their Market study I
suspect they might do next week but just
to be clear I don't know which one of
you it is that's not playing ball with
the CMA but Jonathan Collins thank you
chair and follow on from Mr mangle's
point I mean uh to be perfectly
transparent I'm someone who supports and
has worked with Fairfield UK who's been
calling for this pump watch introduction
similar to what we see in Northern
Ireland so I'm very delighted to hear
that we have all the major uh the 44 uh
four Court share essentially in the road
fuels Market space now supporting this
campaign and that'll be good news for
the chancellor who I know he's been
engaging with the Department of Business
and trade and others to hear their views
on this matter
the chart you know this government since
2010 has frozen fuel Duty for over a
decade we've seen two cuts to uh the
actual cost and we saw the chance that
having uh worked myself and the Sun
newspaper campaign for uh the 5p cut to
remain in place yet
sadly consumers don't believe for a
single second that carton fuel juice has
ever been passed on to the consumer
because ultimately these stubbornly high
prices particularly for diesel drivers
has meant that they feel that they're
being taken advantage of and the
competition of markets Authority
themselves have said that between 2017
and 2022 the profit margin for
supermarkets in fuel has gone from was
double from four percent to eight
percent
do you think what the CMA says said
there is reflective of what you're
seeing within your businesses and do you
see or can you explain why customers
didn't see that 5p cotton fuel Duty and
the continuation of that scheme passed
on into their pockets if I start with
you Mr Potts
the duty we did uh pass that on the same
day and
um clearly the volatility within the
market has to be tracked over time I
think
[Music]
um
we have provided everything that the CMA
has asked for and would continue to do
so
um
I think there is a bit more profit
actually at the retail end of fuel I
couldn't be specific on the time scales
but if that is roughly eight I'm going
to go away from this meeting inspired to
have a look at the 92 and
three things we've done this year for
consumers on fuel we've added more card
points to every liter of fuel our
consumers our customers buy forgive me
we've run three promotions on our fuel
which would have lasted nine weeks which
I know has helped and we strengthened
our pricing policy
within that local catchment so it's
actually tougher for us to hit our price
policy within the spreads
um I I think I think we can always do
more the energy costs that exists the
transport costs the labor costs within
our sites they all have added to the
dollar pound to the oil barrel uh post
Russia and so on so
you know if if I may just for a moment
go right back I do think over four
decades the British supermarkets have
brought
lower prices to consumers in Britain for
fuel these are facts and right now the
fuel prices on our Supermarket Four
Courts are lower than the independence
and continue well of course let's go
back to Mr mangle's point you will be
able to have a better purchasing power
than an independent four Court which
will be able to therefore drive down
those costs and my concern is the
competition of Marcus Authority
basically gave a slap on the wrist to
the supermarkets over uh fuel prices and
within two weeks of the competition
Market Authority giving a uh ticking off
to the supermarkets Suddenly by some
miracle we saw four Court price on
average come down by 7p per liter so it
took naming and shaming for the
competition of Marx Authority for
dramatically 7p overnight to be found
off your margins why was it in that case
that 7p was not passed on prior to the
competition marks Authority making any
statement if I come to you sorry again
Mr Paul so that's okay of course I think
it's a very a very fair question but the
um
if I take the exact same day last year
as today we are about 48p a liter lower
and so the seven I'm sure is in there
somewhere with the five
but I I think I would only be repeating
myself in the interest of time I I
appreciate Mr Fox because Mr comfort as
they used to be a market leader in
having a lost leader at the pump in
order to build brand loyalty and bring
people into the store as it seems to
have abandoned that policy of being a
lost leader and actually has gone for
the more profiteering which is why
people feel that essentially I'm not
going to take a word I know Ms Han's
going to use later but a a feeling
there's a collective group thing here in
this space it's meaning that we're not
seeing competition in the market space
as there once was why did azer abandon
that Halo I think effect it was referred
to as the by the quantity Authority why
did it abandon the Lost leader of the
Palm to build the brand loyalty with the
store
but there's the fuel pricing strategy
policy hasn't changed
um over many years right we are still
recognized as the CMA have said that
we're still recognized as the best value
for your providers I mean Asda is still
a lost leader in fuel so the the overall
strategy of us to be the best value for
fuel retailer in the UK has not changed
you wouldn't have seen profit margins
going from four to eight percent we have
we look at everything in its total round
as was said earlier our full year
profits in 2022 for total as to which is
food fuel in the total business have
dropped by 25 off a back back um
background of a sales line being flat so
we we don't we look at everything and
it's total entirety you are also having
to pay whopping debt back as uh Mr the
chair Mr Jones pointed out because the
fact that you had a new buyer come into
the company only put 800 million pounds
of their own money therefore heavily
debt laid in the business which is why
we're now seeing nearly half a billion
pounds of debt being resurfaced so
essentially you would have had to have
made more money in order to be able to
service the debt because the debt deal
from what I understand was the market
rate of five percent plus an additional
six percent so 11 interest rate on the
debt that you're paying would that not
therefore lead to the fact that that's
why reality is whilst you may still
remain the most competitive it is not
far off it's no longer the Lost leader
it was to build or bring the customer
into the store for Asda and therefore
you are probably making double profit
margins as the CMA has suggested as I
said in my opening statement the the
ownership structure hasn't changed the
business decision to invest in customers
therefore we have invested in in as we
said in the food elements of just
Essentials uh of Asda rewards and and
kids eat for a pound and and you know
it's recognized by the CMA that we are
still the best value food fuel provider
that has remained unchanged can I check
Mr Comfort you're not the company that
the CMAs referred to as quote at least
one supermarket has significantly
increased its internal forward-looking
margin Target since 2019 that wouldn't
apply to Asda I haven't gone through the
full details of the CMA reporters due
out I believe in the next few weeks with
recommendations and we will review those
recommendations accordingly
um and and Implement any recommendations
that come forward and if we as a
committee request internal documents
from you would you would we find
evidence of this or would you be willing
to share those documents
if you I'm sorry I missed that video if
we as a committee ask the internal
documents would we find evidence or all
of our documents have been submitted the
CMA have everything we have fully
engaged with them on everything I have
been to the CMA we've had the
conversations they have all of our
documentation if I come to yourself Miss
Barton and I'll I'm Mr gaffer on the
27th of March 2023 the CMA noted that
the average diesel retail margins were
more than three times the size of
average petrol retail margins at over 23
Pence per liter compared to seven Pence
per liter
I say it's obviously referred to my
interest on someone who drives a diesel
car chair so sort of put that on the
record but do these margins do these
figures align with your own or have your
margins come down since if I start with
you miss partner then you Mr gaffer
so
there is 141 and 140 so
whilst you know in this kind of format I
can't comment specifically on margins
for individual products so I wouldn't be
allowed to do that
um what we what we have seen through a
very volatile period is finally some
stability so wholesale prices have been
highly volatile supply has been highly
volatile it's been one of the most
difficult years I would say to operate
in this market
it's also a market that's in steep
decline so volumes are reducing as
people Electrify their vehicles
and so we are managing
um
a situation for customers as best as we
possibly can trying to keep prices as
low as we possibly can which is what we
have always done we've always had the
same pricing policy to match at the
local catchment area
there was a period of time where Diesel
and petrol prices were further apart
than they've historically been and that
that was fairly short-lived
you say about electrification Miss part
that's coming down the track so what's
the plan if more and more people
Electrify will is the long-term plan
that four courts will disappear from
supermarkets or are we going to keep
prices High to actually make up for the
loss in customers who will charge at
home we've committed to providing petrol
for our customers as long as they need
it and as long as we possibly can but
clearly in parallel with that we'll be
starting to think about how can we
provide an EV infrastructure because
that's where all the new demand will be
Mr gaffer sorry if I come to you as well
please on the first question which is
obviously about uh the margin on diesel
reportedly now being around 23 Pence per
liter compared to seven Pence per liter
that matches with what Tesco's seeing uh
not not at the moment I think as
um as I said earlier we we do price
um in each and every local area and we
do look every day at 8 000 sites and
make sure that um we are competitive I
actually want to say specifically on
diesel
um with it's the part of our price
policy and we believe to have led the
market down to make sure that we gave as
soon as we were confident that the
volatility which we have experienced
which has been really quite tremendous
in in petrol pricing as far as we were
confident we could do so we went and let
out and reduced prices outside of our
policy pretty quickly to make sure that
we could return value you would you
would disagree with the CMA who in May
said that they felt diesel prices quote
remain elevated end quote even the
wholesale price of a diesel have been
falling since the start of 2023. I think
in in any particular week there will be
volatility and there will be variations
the import important it's important to
look at
the return that we make on fuel over
here
and as a Tesco businesses are therefore
pens in every pound is what Tesco makes
from from our operations there will be
volatility even up to in its peak it was
even up to 10 pence per liter per week
that we were seeing which is quite was
quite significant and very difficult to
deal with to be honest because before
the last point before I surrendered my
time is just that my concern is that the
chair as clearly pointed out from the
accounts that profits have gone up to
above what they were pre-pandemic levels
overall before tax
and you're all saying it's not coming
from the stores with people buying food
so therefore it must be coming from the
fuel court because otherwise I don't see
how in Tesco's case we're making 400
million pounds more pre-tax in 21 22 I
think it was referred to compared to 18
19. it just leaves me baffled but I'll
hand over to you too
we'll have to keep that as a comment not
a question I'm afraid because of time
just Ray lastly Mark palsy and then
we'll come to food prices thank you
um I wanted to go stick with the CMA
report if I may
um do each of you agree with the
assertion of the um CMA that there is
evidence of retailer margins increasing
on fuel over the last four years that
was evidence that the CMA gave before
this committee only a couple of weeks
ago do you agree with the CMA Mr Duffer
we are one of the retailers that has
really collaborative Colombia
Mississippi have the CMA got it right or
got it wrong
as one of the retailers as extensively
collaborated with the CMA that will be
representative of what we have seen yes
so is that yes or no I I you have the
CMA got it right away wrong when they
say that retailer margins have increased
I can't comment specifically because we
are in a panel let's move on to Mr
Comfort the CMA right or wrong sir
the CMA of all the information we've
shared everything with them I was like
we're keen to see is the reports the
output of their study which will be out
in a few weeks time they're so they're
wrong in suggesting that there's
evidence of increasing retailer margins
I haven't seen the report yet miss
Marlette the CMA right or wrong
retailer margins are in change we will
need to wait for the report so the CMA
wrong in your view in their assertion
that there are there is evidence of
rising retailers they are the only ones
that can see all of the information so
we need to wait for them to you accept
what they say
say
well despite it being the lowest margin
category in the store I as I said
earlier I think to a colleague forgive
me
um I think there is a bit more profit on
fuel the CMA have got it right right
brilliant okay and one of the things
today and I want to say is more
competition in the sector and they're
talking about perhaps you've already
told us about putting the price on uh
the full cut which I think is an
obligation anyway but how about things
like readily providing your information
to apps so that uh consumers can
determine where the lowest prices I mean
would anybody take an initiative on it
on something such as that
as I said um as I said earlier we we
welcome honestly uh price transparency
in the sector and if we need to submit
um information in an app or a website
like that is in Northern Ireland we
would be happy to do so and have you got
any other ideas as to how the market
consumers can know more how the prices
can be made more competitive I think
digitization an app and usage of the
pricing being visible online is it
happens in full detail now where when we
have strong promotions I'll give you a
very practical example hot deals UK will
show that promotion and customers vote
for it is really something that they
like and we welcome that because it
shows the customers online where there
is good value on the market okay any a
few other eyewitnesses got any
suggestions as to how we can communicate
more effectively prices to Consumers so
that we get better competition in the
sector I think
includes Drive times and the potential
cost of traveling to any particular
location if you put your region and we'd
be very supportive of that kind of
initiative and Mr Potts would you
support that initiative
well consumers are very Savvy I've not
seen that change
um and I think I said earlier we're very
happy to look at anything
that drives a better deal for consumers
including fuel Mr Comfort would you also
make your data available to an app so
that consumers can know where the
cheapest fuel is in their area
yes definitely because they can make the
right choices and decide when they're on
their Journey why wouldn't we help thank
you just a health warning to colleagues
um I've got a maximum of 45 minutes and
10 people to call so please try to keep
your questions focused and Witnesses
please straight to your answers straight
so that we can get through it at Jane
hunt please thank you very much chair
I'm on to food pricing inflation please
so food pricing inflation Rose to over
19 in March this year the highest rise
in food prices since 1978. to what
extent have food prices been hit and
which ones have been worst hit and why
because I stop Mr Potts please
let me just move across thank you uh
well we've certainly seen eggs if I give
a specific example and and a why the
avian flu as I understand it
um
we lost 420 million birds around the
world and therefore you know the the
protein itself the meat itself and the
eggs
particularly the eggs have become in a
short supply
okay just on that point Mr Parks
um a producer has told me that their
prices have only increased by 14 and
they have passed those on accordingly
just that no extra and yet we see in our
notes that actually egg prices have gone
up by 29 what do you say to that
well absence of the detail I think eggs
have actually gone up a lot more than
both those if I may if I may put it that
way and we know how important they are
I think
um they have started to build the flocks
and the eggs are starting to come
through across the whole of the UK
actually including Northern Ireland and
so I I am hopeful and expecting to see a
gradual normalizing of the egg price I
think the other example would be pork
where
a sort of almost an oversupply of pigs
led to a sort of reduction in the
rearing and the finishing of pigs across
the world uh just at a time when sort of
demand was going up and that has put
what is relatively a cheap meat a very
important protein of course uh put that
under pricing pressure
thank you Mr Potts forgive me we're
under time pressure at Miss Bartlett not
eggs not pork what what others so that
the big pressures on inflation have been
a combination of wages and labor energy
and then commodity costs moving around
and the way that we've seen that coming
through the system is in kind of fresh
and chilled food it comes through much
faster and in packaged and long life
food it takes a little bit longer
so
um we've seen prices increase the most
and the fastest in produce and in meat
fish and poultry
um
alongside that there are other
pressures in the system such as the ones
that David refers to where we've got
agriculture pressures
but the core drivers of inflation have
been labor energy and then Commodities
which are relatively cyclical we're
seeing prices some of those fresh food
prices that I talked about start at the
commodity price start to ease so we've
started to see some prices come down so
you'll probably have seen media about
milk about bread butter cheese I'll come
on to that actually in in just a moment
yeah forgive me for interrupting you Mr
Comfort any comment
exactly similar to those obviously we
saw in in February as well some salad
shortages
um so therefore it just shows some of
the fragility in there so the price
increases are due to shortages there was
an element of that on some of the other
projects there's some structural
challenges and then as we said before
that anything that requires energy
labor markets all of these things that's
why we've seen some global commodity
challenges on the rest of it thank you
Mr Gaff for anything to add on that
point yeah I just wanted to build on um
as bartner's Point uh particularly maybe
spending a minute on the role of own
label in the UK
we are as Tesco quite proud that 50 of
what we sell is actually retailer
branded and that is one of the most
developed own label markets in the world
I underlined that point because it
offers a real unique tool in the UK for
customers to manage their weekly budget
and if you think of all label part
particularly because we have invested
I'm quite proud personally to have led
it when I joined Tesco a lot of time
Building open book cost models on our
label with long-term contracts that give
transparency you tend to see inflation
in Commodities flow through fairly
quickly because there is nowhere to go
but actually and you can see some of
those changes in milk and bread as
cereals start to decline and the farm
gate milk price starts to decline you
see those coming back and signs of
inflation and food inflation easing are
clear for us to say thank you very much
Mr Gafford both of you managed to cover
off two of my next two questions really
which I'll just roll into one so you
FAO food price index shows the price of
various Commodities oils cereals Dairy
and meat has fallen since last summer
and yet those prices don't seem to have
been reduced in the supermarkets and
which says their own brand budget items
have risen by 25 so the ones you're
referring to and the ones that Asda
referred to earlier on increased by 25
compared to compared to the previous
year each one of you as you've spoken to
my colleagues earlier on have talked
about Aldi price match meeting the Aldi
prices is this in fact pegging prices
Mr gatha
um it is not begging prices it's Aldi is
a German retailer that has got very
competitive prices we have grown the
coverage of Aldi as well the price
significant investment
um I think it's important just to go
back on the FAO point and the price full
price index there are degrees varying
degrees of inflation some of it is more
sticky than others so the labor cost
increases the adentesco the RMR
competitors the RMR Supply base don't
tend to go away so there is some fairly
structural inflation that is still in
the system and doesn't tend to change as
quickly as the more transitory inflation
that you see in some of the Commodities
that we've described
on that point I'm really quite pleased
that we've laid out on milk we've let
out on cooking oils some flower oil that
had an exponential impact driven by the
Ukraine war 60 of the sunflower crop in
the world comes out of Ukraine and we
had to really fight hard for customers
to secure the availability pay more but
now the actual situation has is that
more sunflower is coming out you can see
and we've gone down and we hope to do
more as more of that transitory
deflation comes to a reduced inflation
thank you Mr gaffer so Mr Comfort I'm a
capitalist in the free market economy
but is this actually free
it is what free Mark the pricing Market
within the supermarkets there are a
small number of you in 1978 there were
many many more supermarkets I remember
because I was that I'm that old I was
around at the time there were very few
supermarkets now and you each talk about
Aldi are you in fact a cartel
the UK retail Market is the most
competitive market I've worked in
Central Europe I've worked in Asia as
some of uh my competitive set and this
is strange today alongside a table who I
compete against on a day by day my teams
compete against we are trying to drive
do our best customer offer to grow our
market share this is quite a uh a unique
opportunity or situation that myself and
and my peers find ourselves in today we
absolutely not we are driven by growing
our business by being from our customers
we have transparency in so far as we can
see the prices that our competitive sell
to their products on a daily basis
either through the internet or in the
stores so that's what drives us and
that's what motivates us and and as
Mr Potts said earlier customers are
really Savvy they absolutely will will
make decisions to who do they shop to
based on the pricing so it's on the onus
is on us to be the best value apologies
I'm going to need to move on I'm afraid
I'm so sorry thank you in Lavery please
thanks uh thanks very much
it's been described by Sharon Graham the
uh General sector of United Union that
the the biggest supermarkets in the UK
are engaged in in a court grotesque
display of profiteering at this time at
a time when millions of workers are
struggling simply they put forward on
the table what do you say to that
just very very briefly
as I said before we we make and this is
the whole group
four pens in every pound
um which I don't think is a
any example of profiteering we really
without customers and with other threads
there is no Tesco and we have doubled
down
on our competitiveness and genuinely as
we've said recently in our quarterly
update we are the most competitive we
have ever been we monitor our prices
weekly I get a price index against the
whole market and it's the strongest
there has been a significant investment
for colleagues for customers and work in
collaborative with suppliers
25 reduction in our full year
profitability in 2022 wouldn't dictate
or reflect that comment that you've just
shared with me
so we make less than three pence in the
pound we've also seen profits step back
and as I said earlier the input cost
pressures that we've had have not been
reflected in full shelf Edge prices so
we're doing absolutely everything we can
we really understand how much customers
and also colleagues are struggling
through this crisis we're doing
absolutely everything we can to make
sure that we're helping them
thank you well I mean I I agree with you
that the most important thing we can do
for consumers right now is to find ways
to lower prices
and
um
yeah I I I'm not seeing any evidence
that the industry is less
competitive than it ever was
and I think the answers earlier to
profitability probably underline that
actually
we'll I'll come on later
um later on this morning with regard to
the
um the the the the the the profits
um so I'm not I'm not like asking any
questions on that as much I find that
absolutely staggering
um but I put a wheel to come under that
uh later on this morning at a time you
know when we've got more children living
in poverty uh an increase in my region
of fifty thousand
um last year and we've got the food
Foundation see it down the last 12
months to January 23 through security
for children doubled
um to think that the top supermarkets
feel as if they're doing the right thing
quite frankly uh is really concerning is
profit and risk in the supply chain
fairly shared by the food producers
produce processors and supermarkets
particularly in a high inflationary
environment and follow an external shock
such as major weather events Awards
so um we sell both branded items as well
as um own label items and I said earlier
unlabeled we tend to have longer term
contracts particularly in Fresh Foods
that um
really work on pricing collaboratively
with our suppliers and I want to go back
to for example the point on eggs we have
paid 28 million more in support to the
egg industry last year as Mr Potts said
we have supported the pork industry as
well so I'm quite proud being in Tesco
that for the seventh year running the
advantage survey which is an industry
survey has placed Tesco first with
regards to supplier satisfaction about
working with us it's not not easy but I
am quite proud of that because it
signifies how we want to work with our
suppliers and how we do work with our
suppliers
um
yeah so look well our relationship on I
believe we have positive working
relationships with our suppliers I've
known them over a long period of time
we work with them we review their costs
we review where they're seeing
Commodities in a similar way our
relationship is also very closely
regulated quite rightly by the grocery
code adjudicator who I believe you're
seeing shortly and therefore we work
with them and they have know they have a
vehicle to talk to if they don't share
things with the or with retailers they
have another vehicle another route
through as well
thanks can I ask you another very brief
question
in the the like the tech Tesco Express
Sainsbury's Louisville exit really like
the satellite supermarkets and they
assume your own brand uh or DSL your own
brand Placebo items uh in the in these
type of outlets
and start a day
um well we're new to that game and uh
convenience stores having just taken
McCall's out of administration we're
just busily rescuing those jobs in that
business so I'm very happy to look at
whether we can get particularly in this
moment of high food inflation whether we
can get some of those sort of fighter
brands that I described earlier so
you're not you're not important you know
we just take we weren't in that section
if I just spend one few seconds I want
to just make one point which is your
earlier question
um we despite being the smaller
company on this panel we are British
farming's biggest single Supermarket
customer
and we are I believe the second biggest
food maker in Britain despite being the
smaller supermarket chain so we believe
very strongly in British food security
which is why we only stock 100 British
food coming from Beef Pork and lamb I
just thought that point ought to be made
yeah he's welcome
um to answer your point on risk and
reward we work very closely with our own
brand suppliers so in many instances we
have open book cost models and that's
one of the reasons why inflation moves
more quickly inflation and deflation
when you operate that kind of model
because the retailer
shares and takes lots of the commodity
and labor energy pricing risk
um that's not the model with Brands as
you would expect so with Brands we've
got no transparency really about what
their input costs are and so it's a
different kind of conversation
to the question on convenience stores
and how we range them and what we stock
in convenience stores so there's lots of
own brand inconvenience stores
there isn't as much of the economy brand
which is what I think you were referring
to
most of our convenience stores are in
City centers and they serve a lunchtime
Mission or a dinner for tonight Mission
so we have 30 000 products in our big
supermarkets we have five or six
thousand in a convenience store and so
we're very constrained on space so we
range for the mission that the customer
is shopping that store for most
customers do their full shop in a
supermarket and not in a convenience
store
okay
a couple of just brief questions to Mr
Comfort I think we all agree
while agree that that during the
pandemic the Fantastic employees uh of
all the top supermarkets
um you know the heroic efforts of the
employees were whale uploaded and
deserve credit then in the deserved
credit now I mean if it wasn't for these
employees in in your Supermarket this
year wouldn't be making these these huge
profits but a question that must have
come off that
um
it appears that as there are still using
fire and rehire uh they do not believe
in the Southeast improves the 60 Pence
per day
peer cut on 7 000 retail workers
um
is that right
so firingly higher tactics are not
something that as their employees it
absolutely isn't what you are I believe
referring to is a historical supplement
that was paid into a small number of
stores so therefore as a result there
was an anomaly where
some as the colleagues were paid a
different rate to ones in an adjacent
area what we've chosen to do to fix it
is look at our total business and
therefore reward an eight percent pay
increase to the total hourly pay
colleagues last year followed by a
further 10 this year we're using fire
and rehire tactics absolutely not
definitely not
turkey that's fine and then another
brief question again it refers to Asda
Mr commenters with regard to the fact
that as there are currently in the the
largest equal pay claim uh in the
private sector ever with over 50 000
claimants currently suing us therefore
it will appear there's a huge difference
between the the retail and the warehouse
uh workers and in the main women it's
women who are working in retail in Maine
who will work in in the warehouse and
there's a discrepancy of at least three
pound an hour which is an absolute
Fortune now next and other organizations
have been through their tribunal
hearings that's been in the favor of the
workers now the reality is is that I
believe that um Asda over here and
coming up on the the 20 uh in September
2024 uh if that's the case if you lose
that it means I gonna have to pay
millions if not billions of pounds of
money back to the workers it'll have an
impact on your profits what it means is
uh Mr you've been making huge profits on
the back of underpaid women would you
agree with it no that's why we're
vehemently defending these claims the
pay in our stores and our distribution
centers
um is the same for colleagues doing the
same jobs regardless of gender
what you are referencing is the fact
that the retail jobs and the
distribution
centers operate differently and
therefore are in different sectors with
different skills and therefore get
people get remunerated differently for
the different areas that they work in it
has nothing to do with gender look the
case is really complicated it's a
complex case there's no precedent in the
private sector that I'm aware of and
therefore we are aware of the uh the
conversation that will continue until
September 24th okay thank you and
colleagues I'm going to call colleagues
that haven't had a chance to ask a
question in that order if that's okay
and if there's time at the end then I'll
reallocate it to others so I'm going to
go
um Sir Robert Anthony Ian and Andy in
that order yeah
um
this delivery touched on the sort of
relative power of supermarkets compared
to processors and manufacturers and
certainly compared to Farmers at sort of
bottom end of what literally is the food
chain and I'd like to direct my uh
question to Mr gaffer uh Mr Fox talked
about what happened this time last year
in the egg market and um although bird
flu did have an impact only about 0.25
of the chickens in this country are
affected me geese turkeys it was garnish
but
um but what we did see we saw the price
of chicken feed doubling following the
the inversion of Ukraine and when the
Packers came to the supermarkets and
said look you're gonna have to do
something otherwise we won't have any
eggs by the Autumn the supermarket said
basically no we've got a contract you
could Supply at that price and what
happened then is that as the sort of
13-month cycle of laying hens came round
a number of producers either retired or
didn't fill up their sheds so come the
Autumn there weren't any eggs and you
have to ship them in from from Italy so
do you think in that in that quest to
actually absolutely drive down prices
sometimes the supermarkets lose touch
with the reality of producing food and
say well you know we don't care you know
these farmers are going to lose money
they're going out business we look
careless we can sell eggs cheaply today
whereas in this in the case of pork and
and eggs and broilers actually the
long-term effect was was not to the
benefit of your customers
hey thanks Robert
um I'll I am the commercial director for
packaged food so I don't look after
fresh however I do have a little bit of
knowledge having worked in some fresh
departments so I'll answer the best of
my knowledge uh we have asdasco we have
never shipped any Italian eggs we have
no intention to ship any European eggs
we are committed to 100 British first
and foremost
um and this was in my time actually
setting up our
um commodity steam as we call it where
we opened up and I believe we were
leaders in the industry
um open open cost models with our egg as
well as chicken suppliers where we go
all the way up to feed and transparently
make joint decisions with our Packers on
when to buy that feed we've done
five-year contracts on areas like eggs
for example which is a big commitment
but we recognize is required our
commitment to British eggs fresh British
chicken I think that was the problem
there were long-term contracts which
didn't take account of the short-term
fluctuations in Tesco specifically those
contracts again to the best of my
knowledge are transparent and do vary
from feed because we go all the way to
looking at wheat pricing and soya
pricing with the Packers and determine
when we should buy together and as I
mentioned earlier last year we paid 28
million more to the egg industry to
support those really hard times that you
refer to
you think maybe there could be more
collaborative workings say following the
example of McCain Foods who actually
contract with their Farmers based on the
price of fuel Machinery all the other
inputs they need you think maybe we need
a little bit more collaboration rather
than just you know your guys with their
sort of red braces on in your purchasing
department crushing people trying to
supply you
as I say number one for seven years
running in the advantage survey which
includes our fresh food for our Fresh
Food suppliers as well as our package
from suppliers and indication of how we
collaborate again supplier satisfaction
our own Viewpoint that we send to
suppliers 86 really high numbers
um I am a huge advocate of transparency
in the in the supply chain I remember
having some really quite at the time
um they call them revolutionary I don't
know maybe it's the bigger word but
changing conversations that we're really
proud to have adopted and stuck with and
I think have helped many farmers
continue you to be aligned with Tesco
let's not forget the Tesco sustainable
dairy group which has been in place for
more than 10 years we believe and it's
there to see we've paid more than 300
million to those 500 online Farmers that
are specifically dedicated to Tesco 500
million more over the lifespan of the
Tesco sustainable dairy group I've
visited quite a few of those Farmers
they're really proud and we're really
proud of working with them and we have
more sustainable groups that are and
have launched so more transparency is
not something that we're against with
our supplies at all
thank you maybe to um Miss Bartlett um
there's been some speculation about a
possible statue or voluntary price cup
for customers would you say that be
workable or advantageous
the way it's a very fiercely
that we work in and we've talked quite a
lot this morning haven't we about how
much we're watching and matching each
other's prices all of the time so
we're waiting of course to hear what the
CMA have to say about it but my
observation would be this is fiercely
competitive as a market we're generally
considered one of the most competitive
food markets in the world I'm not sure
what price caps would add to that
process
um other than bureaucracy where we've
seen
um
them applied in France and so on it can
have
unintended consequences of selling out
and other prices moving up and down
around so I think this Market
self-regulates
to a a positive extent so we wouldn't be
in support of price Captain did you have
similar extreme with eggs because I mean
this time last year there were 43
million laying birds in the country by
the Autumn that was down to 38 million
and that wasn't bird flu that was just
farmers losing money and going out of
eggs despite what we heard Mr Gallas say
so eggs is one of the most fragmented
Supply chains that we deal with so we've
spent the last 10 or 20 years sort of
supporting the consolidation of
different Supply chains so that we can
play a more active
role in making sure safe and good value
food comes through the system eggs
probably is further behind some of the
other value chains we primarily deal
with Packers and not with farmers and I
think that's been a problem
over the last 12 months or so we have
imported eggs from Italy because we
wanted customers to have eggs we have a
policy that we want to be 100 British
but there wasn't the supply and there
hasn't been the supply for the best part
of the year that is coming back on
stream now the suppliers tell me that
new egg sheds there's long delays in
planning permissions so if
shares up and down the country that
farmers didn't fill when the this time
last year and during the summer that was
a problem yeah so that I mean the
farmers that we're engaging with as we
try and get further back into the supply
chains are calling out planning
permission is something that would help
them at this stage thank you thank you
so much Ian
thank you I'm going to last two
questions or just yes no answer yeah
sport let's just touched on one with the
one that lasted
the images of baby formula milk and lots
haunts me I hope and horns use in light
of what the MF AMF reported today about
profited and causing inflation
would you lay your counterpart in France
cap or support capping essential items
Gordon
yes or no we we no no yes or no I've got
no time
um you you can't compare France to the
UK in mind no you can't yeah when you've
got baby locks around for me I'm asking
a question can you just give me a
handset yes or no would you support we
don't believe prices
go support Place caps David
uh
uh no David
I'm just checking in on the question
right do you support price caps on a
sense of food items like baby milk which
are now a lot in other words
I I I I would say competition leads you
to the right place actually okay the
industry requires volume and you'll see
it come it's okay air so I'm moving on
to uh in light of where we are with the
huge Public Health crisis should be
faced from obesity a lot of it's downl
oh look I'm fine with the government
delaying the uh okay you agree with it I
am we haven't run multibodes on each of
assessed products since 2016. okay so
you don't agree with it Well Done David
yeah I think our job is to execute
government legislation and that's what
we'll do okay so how do you uh again yes
or no why do you promote fast food and
vegetables same extent as food high in
fat salt and sugar
Gordon what's the question again sir are
you promoting fresh fruit and vegetables
in this to the same extent as you're
promoting food high in fat sugar and
salt so we believe that fresh food
should be as much off promotion and
competitive of everyday low price as
possible listen
when you walk into our stores you see
fruit and veg promotions yeah
David
yeah we give it away even so okay so the
last question do you legally but the
food Minister that obesity can be
successfully tackled primarily through
just informing customers
Gordon just informing customers about
the effects of obesity instead
actually bring it in measures to tackle
it the nanny stays
not sure I think it needs more than this
I think the helping customers with
healthy sustainable choices whether
that's what we can do to help
reformulate products is is
pardon or government policy well then I
would agree with anything that helps
customers reformulate products for them
yeah we supported each of us it's just
um a frustration that only one of the
three elements of the policy has
actually been implemented so we've
relayed all of our stores
but the multi by component the
advertising component isn't in place and
I think on its own
um location of products probably isn't
enough to make a difference very good
David
well I'm thinking it's a big question
we are opening food desert fresh food
desert places by buying McCall's you'll
have seen it in in Liverpool I think
actually but yeah we'll do everything we
can right thank you thanks yeah thank
you just very very quickly Rianne you
said that Sainsbury's had put a
voluntary ban on how
um fat sugar and salt uh multibodies
um but there's some evidence to suggest
that you are price discounting for your
loyalty customers for HFS products
that's right isn't it yeah that's
correct so we we run promotions but we
don't run multi-buy promotions okay
thank you Anthony thank you chair we've
touched on convenience stores a little
bit the smaller model but I want to just
uh touch on them again I think between
the four of you you've got about three
and a half thousand convenience stores
the absolute line share with you Mr
guffer and Tesco
you must have seen the recent witch
study which said that customers who rely
on those smaller convenience stores the
Tesco Express Sainsbury's local
Morrisons daily and I think it's Asda
local or Asda Express
um now
um the witch report said that they that
customers couldn't access a decent range
of cheap healthy food would you agree
with that categorization Mr gatha
um are arranging in Express
um hey first and foremost we're really
very competitive and expressed and again
we compare our pricing
um weekly in that channel
um our ranging in Express is based on
customer insight and we do make real
careful choices because there's a lot of
brands that we range and express that
are very important to the customers that
shop locally in those stores all right
when you say you do based on customer
Insight is it that based on customer
demand or by research you're conducting
a bit about so um we I'll give you an
example let's say in the in our Bolton
Express we decide that um because we
just want to arrange on label we won't
have any of the Branded Brad I think
we'd have a little bit of a problem
because of the Loyalty that certain
branded suppliers have in those doors
and that's what I mean
um we just on the point on affordability
we have last year introduced Club prices
also in Express to make sure that our
promotions are also available in that
channel
I mean you'll have seen in the same
witch report that they say that the
customers who rely on those stores so
they're not using it for convenience the
ones who rely on those stores are
typically lower income with less access
to cars or good public transport
so what are you doing to help make sure
in those stores there are better there's
a better range of own brand Essentials
and what more could you do
we do constantly review our ranges in
fact this year we are reviewing all the
vast majority of our merchandising
groups will be to be accurate so we'll
be constantly looking to see if there's
areas where we can
help with different introductions but as
I say through
really competitive pricing across that
convenience market and through the the
value that clubcard gives
um we think we deliver really good would
you agree with the categorization that
the customers who rely on those stores
are typically lower income is that your
experience there's there's a broad in my
experience there is abroad that depends
on location there's a broad customer
base and we're proud to serve millions
of customers through those okay so there
are some of those convenience stores
that will have a lower income
demographic who rely on them in those
stores are you prioritizing essential
items a known brand over others and we
arrange in those stores that we believe
you know are the ranges that are
relevant for those customers if there
are any specifics that we need to look
at I'm happy to take it away if there's
any real important ones that we're
missing we don't get it always right but
we think we're competitive we've just
opened our 2000 Express store because we
really see The Importance of Being where
customers want to to be okay
um Miss partner I think you're the
second biggest in terms of convenience
stores are you doing enough to help
those who rely on those stores
yeah so as I said earlier that
um we would range according to the
customer Mission so we don't find
customers in the most part would use a
convenience store as their main shop so
most of them are in City and town
centers and cater to a lunchtime and a
just after work dinner Mission we do
have some that we call Neighborhood hubs
which are in more neighborhood areas
those catchments are really well served
by supermarkets we're very rarely the
only store we would range according to
demand also but we segment that demand
we use a lot of our loyalty data to
support us with this
according to which
missions that customer is shopping in
those stores so that we can give them
we're very very constrained ranges we
need to give customers what they want to
buy in that store on that day
knowing that most of their shop is going
to a larger Supermarket or to an online
offer okay Mr pot I'm going to you're
obviously growing quite significantly
yeah
I think
first of all thank you for the idea I
think I think it's a well-made point if
I may say
I was on the housing estate in Aberdeen
a couple of weeks ago and that felt like
the type of thing you're getting at
where I just use a Tesco Express writes
outside that Tube Station over the road
which I think has got a different level
of elasticity right now and I take that
point
um as you say we're new into this game
but I
believe there's plenty of own brands in
the convenience stores across Britain
we have lowered the prices opposite in
the course to 10 by up to 10 percent
where'd you get when you go to Morrisons
daily as a conversion
but I am happy to shove a few Savers
that we talked about earlier in this
meeting into those stores especially up
until the food inflation normalizes in
this country I think it would be a good
thing to do particularly in those areas
where people are relying on that site
thank you very much
um just one final question if I can
um so if we think about the the
customers we're talking about uh more
vulnerable lower income less access to
cars and public transport
um Mr Gafford at Tesla you've got a
minimum online order of 50 pounds and if
you don't hit that you pay a surcharge
are you just pricing out lower income
families from online shopping
that 50 pound minimum basket and that is
double by the way the Morrisons minimum
order
um the 50 pound minimum basket charges
the first change that we've done to that
level in eight years
uh average average basketball average
basket size uh online is 90 pounds so
um and and also by the way there's click
and collect which is still at 25 pounds
with regards to minimum we're talking
specifically about customers
can't access
yeah yeah are you pricing out you know
unless you can click and collect go to a
different Supermarket if you want your
online shopping as I said I believe that
um with the average Market Basket size
being 90 pounds 50 pounds is
um
reasonable with regards to the first
change we've done to that minimum basket
size in eight years and with inflation
with the inflationary pressures and the
number of online orders that we're
sharing we're at about 1.1 million
orders of significantly higher versus
what it was before the pandemic
shot there's not necessarily those on
the lower income
um Miss Butler your minimum order is
slightly lower you're at 40 pounds but
your surcharge is higher at seven pounds
do you think that's fair for a low
income household to pay a search or just
seven pounds
um I'm gonna need to take that one away
actually I I need to get a little bit
closer probably to where we've got
surcharges I know
um click and collect works but it
doesn't answer your point because
um you need a car to click and collect
okay thank you Andy McDonald please uh
thanks chair
um how much are you planning to pay out
in dividends this year
how do these figures compare to the
dividends paid out to shareholders over
the last five years
what's that uh the Tesco dividend this
um 10.9 Pence which is flat yeah
it's covered
privately
we haven't announced our dividend yet
that's
that's very soon
we've currently got no plans to pay any
dividends this year oh right okay
um well I've got something in front of
me that tells me that the the
Tesco and Sainsbury's annual report and
accounts
so show that you plan to pay
859 million pounds and 309 at 319
million pounds in dividends in 2023 and
that according to unite that's your
highest common dividend since 2015 and
that's higher than last year in 2022
Tesco paid out
731 pounds 31 million pounds in
dividends and Sainsbury's paid out
dividends of 238 million
those figures been true with you
effort Tesco specifically we paid last
year 10.9 Pence and we're paying this
year again 10.9 Pence we shouldn't
forget many of our shareholders are also
small retail shareholders that do rely
on dividends and many of our
shareholders are actually colleagues of
the business as well that do supplement
their income with the dividends that the
business pays up
Johnson respond um we're expecting to
announce a dividend that's roughly flat
year on year
okay
um that's that's uh really interesting
but can I come back to you uh Mr gaffer
um
we have got figures in our brief that
show us that the increase in uh share
dividend has increased by 89
since 2018 2019.
is that something that you would
recognize is it
accurate or in or in the in the in the
area
we I haven't got the 2018 number with me
but um
I am the conventional director for
package food so I'm yeah I can give it
to you Mr gaffer if you'd like it um
Tesco 2018 19 uh 5.8 Pence Tesco 22 23
10.9 Pence thank you Mr chair um I think
we it's important to remember that at
Tesco we have been busy restructuring
the business and the the making sure we
are building it we rebuilt a little bit
um to make sure that we are the best for
customers
um throughout the last eight years and
the growth and dividend progression
reflects the growth of the health of the
business to make sure that Tesco isn't a
um sustainable place available to serve
as many customers as we can do you
understand that you have said this
throughout this morning session that the
focus is upon customers to delivering
the best outcomes from them I'm putting
to you figures here about the dividend
payouts which census suggests that the
focus is is elsewhere and that really
does a really impact upon people I think
it's been said before that you know this
business isn't about selling food it's
about making money I think one of your
predecessors said that some years ago
you've talked about it being fiercely
competitive but it's obviously fiercely
profitable as well
um and can I go on then just to look at
I'm looking at Sainsbury's annual
reports and the chief executive I think
that's Mr Mr Roberts
um he's paid almost four million pounds
in in bonuses on top of his salary uh
you know and I'd really like to know how
they you justify that in the in the
midst of a cost of living crisis
um I think if if you look at Mr Roberts
that's 4.9 million 408 000 pounds a
month 94 000 pounds a week two pounds 2
298 pounds an hour and workers have paid
11 pounds an hour I mean you know
how is that justifiable when people the
people who work for you and the people
that come into the stores are suffering
from a grotesque cost of living crisis
now how can that possibly be justified
for as a ballistic company you'll know
that all of our board directors
um salaries are published
by the Remco I don't sit on the Remco I
don't have any remit over setting any of
those salaries
um so I can't really comment any further
on that today
do you not get the point that you know
this this discussion is couched around a
cost of living crisis and yet you know
I've got to say the chief Executives
across the board are in the same
ballpark in terms of their their their
their their their pay do you understand
how that sits with the general public
that these sorts of words is being
played and you tell us that your purpose
is to provide the most reasonably priced
food for your customers and yet
Dividends are paid out and these
salaries at this level
does that not shine with any of you
can make football
no I I just absolutely utterly
staggering quite frankly um Chad I just
want to finish with a a point that my
colleague of slavery raised about as
they're in the Southeast and I ask you
Mr Comfort will Asda commit to
collectively bargain on paying
conditions for its retail workers the
majority of whom are women will you
commit today to collective bargaining
the collected but so what will the
recognition of the GMB and collectively
bargain with them over these matters we
have a an open relationship with the GMB
we speak with the GMB
um collectively and together and we
speak with them frequently and we'll
discuss anything with them will you
collectively bargain with them will you
will you will you enter into collective
bargaining agreement with the GMB as
Chief commercial officers stand here
today I can't commit to that but
absolutely I will take it away with my
team and we will discuss it at a board
level
thank you chair
thank you
um we've timed out unfortunately but we
may have to come back some further
questions either in subsequent written
form or maybe in further hearings and I
know our colleagues on the effort
committee are looking at the structural
issues under pricing underpinning food
price changes as well so I look forward
to the evidence that your organizations
give to them and of course we've got the
CMA reports coming as well which may be
a reason for us to come to come back to
you but thank you to all four of you for
this morning we're now going to do a
very quick changeover and welcome in the
groceries code adjudicator
um Mark White thank you very much
yeah thank you
true that's true see you later
good morning Mr White thank you for
bearing with us we're running a little a
little over so we're grateful to you and
we will have to finish at midday today
um I'm afraid um the first question just
just for the record for people watching
could you please explain uh what it is
you and your organization does indeed
thank you chair so I'm Mark White I'm
the groceries code adjudicator and I'm
the person appointed to regulate the
groceries code between the 14 designated
retailers selling more than a billion
pounds a year each of groceries and
their direct suppliers and what
specifically does your organization have
in terms of powers around food price
inflation
so uh food price inflation
um in terms of pricing itself is not
part of the code so either retail
pricing to consumers or retailers
pricing with suppliers however inflation
clearly is a concern across the economy
and in this sector in particular and I'm
very conscious of everything that the
committee has heard today in terms of
consumer pricing and so having engaged
with suppliers about the process for
setting cost price increases I set out
to agree with the retailers seven gold
rules in January 2022 to regulate the
way in which those cost price
negotiations are conducted to provide
transparency to provide detail about how
long the process would take so to ensure
that the process is fair or the so I
cannot set price one of the things that
I'm left with having listened to the
evidence just now is a concern that
whilst we might have a competitive
market uh the kind of customer front
door in the supermarkets
the the resilience of the structure
doesn't feel like it's in the right
place they're all very
um exposed to international events
whether it's climates supply chain
disruption Energy prices uh paperwork uh
tariffs you know all of that type of
stuff seems to be adding a lot of cost
and a lack of resilience underpinning
the supermarkets and we've seen that in
the energy sector recently and had to
deal with the consequences of that are
you worried about the resilience of our
food supply chains in the UK so look my
priorities are informed by what is going
on in the sector and also by what
suppliers are telling me and they tell
me things in confidence because I have a
statutory obligation of confidentiality
and since my appointment there have been
all sorts of issues that have faced the
sector so during the pandemic it was
really about suppliers and retailers
working constructively together to
deliver product on shelf for consumers
as we began to come out of the pandemic
some of those issues that you've just
spoken about chair have come to the fore
so we've seen shortages shortages of raw
ingredients issues around hgv drivers
labors that morphed into inflation
generally so committee heard very a few
minutes ago about the cost of feed and
how that has fed in
shortages again on Raw ingredients
packaging costs that have all led to
inflation and so this is a a very
Dynamic sector Energy prices as you've
just mentioned have really impacted and
what I'm hearing from a number of
suppliers that I'm engaged in is that
this could result in insolvences in
their businesses so putting them out of
business and therefore they would not be
Supply to retailers and therefore choice
for the consumer on the Shelf
do you know has anybody I don't know
whether this government or you or the
industry has anybody done an assessment
of the security of the food supply chain
in terms of the resilience assessment
have they looked at that holistically
um
at the farmed Fork Summit that was held
in Downing Street last month that issue
of food security bringing suppliers and
representatives from the supply side and
producers together with some of the
retailers was very much the theme to
begin to look about how we address that
holistic issue of making sure there is
proper Supply local Supply perhaps
to provide consumers with Choice thank
you Anthony thank you chair Mr White
I've just got three uh over the quite
quick questions looking at the the 2023
survey it's obviously good to see that
the percent compliance is increasing but
I wonder what the severity of
non-compliance is is it the case that
whilst compliance has increased the
severity of non-compliant cases has
increased
so the results of the 2023 survey as you
said show an improvement in Code
Compliance notwithstanding the very
difficult year that we have seen in the
sector so if I look back 10 years
co-compliance was at 73 in 2014 on
average now it's 92 percent in my 2023
survey to your point about individual
issues 79 of respondents in the 2014
survey reported that they had had code
issues with retailers in 2023 that was
36 so a reduction 11 out of the 13
retailers uh who were part of the 2022
survey increase their compliance scores
with 8 out of 13 increasing by more than
three percent and if for example I look
at m s their score of 99 was the highest
ever score achieved in a survey so
year on year there are always pockets of
issues which arise and the way in which
I deal with those is to engage with each
retailer on their results to work on an
improvement plan to deliver an
improvement but it's very bespoke
because quite often the issues are very
individual to individual retailers but
you wouldn't or would you say that
um
you know take a typical Supermarket it's
done all the low hanging fruit for one
of a better phrase and so the only
issues left for non commands are they're
really complex serious breaches that's
not what you're seeing no right
okay
um obviously Amazon was included for the
first time in 2023 it's at the bottom of
the table but historically that's where
when the code first came out that's
where you would expect it to be what
plans have you got to work with Amazon
to increase that
so I as you say bottom of the table and
it is of course concerning
um
but if you look back at 2014 that score
is not too dissimilar to What retailers
were scoring back 10 years ago and
retailers scores have improved across
the 10-year period since the survey
started
Amazon has made changes to its processes
so it has made changes to de-listing it
has made changes to notification of
deductions on Forensic audit claims what
the survey helps you do is really
pinpoint those areas for Amazon on which
it needs to work and I will be engaging
with Amazon to work out an improvement
plan and that is no different to the
approach that I will adopt with all of
the retailers if you feel you're getting
the right level of Engagement from
Amazon to dramatically increase their
compliance in short order I am getting
the right level of Engagement there
sometimes a little time delay between
taking action to correct something or to
correct a perception and it delivering
results
I would very much encourage Amazon to
look at its communication to supplies to
really tell them what it is that they
are doing to change and of course if I
may use this opportunity to remind
suppliers to please come and talk to me
if they are experiencing issues with
Amazon I have an absolute obligation of
confidentiality
have you seen a leads me onto another
one have you seen a significant increase
in the number of supplies coming to you
since Amazon was brought into the code
um So at around the time of designation
which was in March 2022 there was an
uptick in the number of suppliers coming
not just to me but also going to the
co-compliance officer at Amazon so I
very much encourage suppliers to go to
the co-compliance officer to raise
issues but then that plateaued and has
come down
thank you I just want to turn very
briefly to indirect suppliers such as
Darren I just want your general view on
expanding the code to include them
so I recognize
um that such a change would be welcomed
by some primary producers
primary producers provide me with very
detailed and very useful insight and I
don't differentiate in my engagement
with suppliers between indirect and
direct because as far as I'm concerned
all of their information is very helpful
um the existing work I do I hope
benefits primary producers so my seven
golden rules in terms of clarity on a
CPI process I hope filters down to the
primary producer and my interventions
with retailers so asking them to have
buyers enroll for two years to improve
their understanding of the category uh
crop growing Cycles is an example where
I'm really hoping that buyers will
better understand the challenges that
are faced by suppliers
commercial models adopted by the
retailers change so many
retailers adopt a model where they go
through a consolidator or a buying desk
but other retailers contract directly
today's primary producer is tomorrow's
direct supplier and a little bit vice
versa
um I think that any changes to scope
would require an examination of whether
the powers that the GCA has are
appropriate for a wider scope we'd need
to look at resourcing
um at the moment I'm regulating a
relatively small number of
retailers with a relatively small team
if that were to change I think that we
would just need to understand what the
financing implications would be and how
the operating model for the GCA would
need to be adapted to ensure that it was
both effective and efficient
you could see a benefit to bringing into
your remit providing you a resourced
appropriately
to do so indeed but I think the
Assassins would need to be done first
thank you thank you Andy yes please uh
you you mentioned the word power uh
which interests me
um because you talk an awful lot about
engagement and encouragement
um but but there's a power imbalance
isn't there between retailers and
suppliers here which is fundamental to
this we heard from the ephra chair that
you know people uh risk when that
business and you say to yourself Mr
White about and those goods not being on
the on the shelves so is there something
to address there fundamentally in this
relationship and and what sort of work
do you think would be needed to be done
to correct it if indeed you think it
does need correcting I think the code
exists to address that power imbalance
uh as identified by the competition
commission back when it reported in 2008
and uh at its heart it is about
transparency in the relationship it is
about not transferring unexpected costs
risks to suppliers and I think that
fundamentally it works but I should say
that a number of retailers do say to me
that there are several suppliers uh to
them who are exponentially larger than
them
and so the power imbalance isn't always
necessarily retailer on supplier
um sometimes we see it the other way
around but what's the proportion is it
more retail more supplier or is it
invariably retailers with power and
suppliers with not
um I think as a general proposition
retailers bigger than suppliers but
there are pockets of suppliers who are
much bigger than retailers as a whole
and then perhaps in certain categories
thank you
there's been a cave
thank you very much
indeed thanks
um just to learn what what Andy's just
been saying with regards to the
suppliers and the the juicy here
reportedly suppliers have been feared
and the past that come forward with any
evidence of any
non-compliance to the juicy and I
surmise that this is largely because of
the might lose the contract I mean and
that's understandable I should imagine
it it appears to be slightly better now
than what it was I'm just wondering what
sort of assurances can you give to the
suppliers in the main that you know
coming forward with evidence the
legislation the regulations that you've
got in place actually are there to
protect them
um so my statutory obligation of
confidentiality is absolute and I take
every opportunity to remind suppliers
um that that exists and that I will
protect their identity
um but I have worked with the retailers
because I recognize this issue and I
secured the retailers agreement in 2021
that co-compliance officers at the
retailers will listen to the concerns of
all suppliers on a confidential basis so
effectively extending my confidentiality
obligation to the retailers and to pass
control over confidentiality to the
supplier so it is up to the supplier to
decide when or if it is comfortable with
information being shared further within
the retailer organization
earlier this year I extended that CCO
confidentiality commitment
with all of the retailers agreeing that
suppliers would not face any negative
consequences should a supplier come to a
retailer to report a code issue so no
retaliation no negative consequences and
then that is being policed within their
organizations
uh in 2021 I set up a completely
Anonymous 24 7 tell the GCA reporting
platform it's available
um in numerous languages to enable
overseas suppliers to contact me and it
enables those suppliers who still do not
wish to come to me and tell me their
name to report a practice or an issue
completely anonymously and I make it
known to suppliers that I will meet them
in any way that they feel comfortable be
it online be it face to face telephone
email however they wish to engage and
reassure them of that obligation of
confidential confidentiality that I have
thank you Mr White I think you sat
through the first session and heard the
answers from the supermarkets do you
have any Reflections on their answers to
our questions
um I think that
um you know what I heard from suppliers
um as inflation began to take off was
the difficulty of penetrating
um the retailer organizations who do you
speak to how do you get a cost price
increase
um agreed and I think the sheer volume
took people by surprise hence I worked
with them on the seven golden rules to
improve the processes and I think that
whilst retailers answers to cost price
increase requests are shown in my 2023
survey are not always the answers that
the supplier wants the processes now are
much smoother I think they've understood
the volume they've got the they've
organized themselves to make sure that
they are able to touch the data that
they need in order to make their
decisions and I think we heard from Mr
Outlet about potential for inflation to
have Plateau that doesn't mean prices
are going down just going up less fast
but then perhaps coming down and I'm
Keen to make sure that my seven golden
rules and those principles that we've
established work on the way down as they
did on the way up one of the interesting
changes in the supermarket Market is the
change in ownership structure so we've
got a couple that are still publicly
listed Tesco and Sainsbury's and then we
have azer that's just been bought
privately but with a very heavy
leveraged debt
purchase Method and then we've got
Morrisons that's just been bought by I
think I'm right saying a private Equity
company do you have any early signs that
the change in ownership or corporate
governance is affecting the behavior of
the supermarkets in any way
not yes okay super anything else you
wanted to say to us before we wrap up
um just please if your constituencies
and sorry the businesses in your
constituences if they do need to contact
me if I could please ask you to share my
name and my details that would be very
helpful I'd be very happy to do that
thank you for bearing with us today and
sorry that it was so short at the end
but we're very grateful to you we're now
called the session to an end order order